[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's do this one last time
my name is Peter Parker I was bitten by
a radioactive spider and for ten years
I've been the one and only spider-man
I'm pretty sure you know the rest great
power comes great I saved a bunch of
people fall in love save the city and
then I say to sit again again and again
and again we don't really talk about
this look I'm a comic book I'm a serial
did a Christmas album I have an
excellent theme song it's so so possible
I mean I've looked worse but after
everything I still love being spider-man
I mean who wouldn't so no matter how
many hits I take
[Music]
I always find a way to come back because
the only thing standing between this
city and oblivion is me there's only one
spider-man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay cool
holy mission I'll you miss me I still
live me
[Music]
seriously dad Walken would have been
fine you come all plenty on Saturday and
build those stickers I saw that I don't
know if that was me that and the two
from yesterday on Clinton oh look at
that
the new coffee shop you see that mouse
totally yeah home party phone party and
everyone is just lying in other did you
see that mouth at a coffee shop or a
disco spider-man I mean this guy swings
in once a day zip zap zop in his little
mask and answers to no one
right yeah that yeah meanwhile my guys
are out there yeah Bob's on the line no
mass no speed up speed up I know these
kids you know with weight ability comes
great accountability that's not even how
the saying goes you like a cereal oh no
oh my gosh don't pops run red lights oh
yes I'm do but uh not your dad
[Music]
why can't I go back to Brooklyn middle
miles you've given it two weeks we're
not having this conversation I just
think that this new school is elitist
and I was prefer to be at a normal
school among the people the people these
are your people
I'm only here cuz I won that stupid
lottery no way you passed the entry test
just like everybody else okay you have
an opportunity here you want to blow
that huh you want to end up like your
uncle's uncle here and he's a good guy
we all make choices in life I doesn't
feel like I have a choice you don't
I love you miles I know that see you
Friday
you gotta say I love you back daddies I
want to hear it I love you dad
I love you that's a copy this is
embarrassing we were the same jacket Hey
solve this for X Y
mr. Morales moving in the dark you're
late again
Einstein said time was relative right
maybe I'm not late maybe you guys are
early sorry it was just so quiet would
you like to keep standing there or do
you want to sit down really I mean it
wasn't funny that's why I left but it
was smart so we're like dying I don't
know I don't think I see I see well what
few more of those you probably have to
kick me out of here huh maybe I'm just
not right for this school if a person
wearing a blindfold picked the answers
on a true/false quiz at random do you
know what score they would get 50%
that's right we only way to get all the
answers wrong is to know which answers
are right you're trying to quit I'm
assigning you a personal essay not about
physics but about you and what kind of
person do you want to be
[Music]
[Music]